okay so first of all that
obviously is not your first comic-con
you're a pro so welcome back to Hall H
and this is a very special movie I want
to know a little bit quickly about how
stoked you are you always been a couple
of enthusiasts you've lived in this
world for a while now how would say is
this particular film for you well it's
cool because I think for me you know
it's really dream come true type of
project because I've always been into
the sort of big icon superheroes and
Batman suit men I mean I don't know
after that what you do it's uh never
been pretty it's pretty epic so yeah
it's it and ballet and getting a chance
to make this particular movie with with
this particular cast I don't know for me
how it gets any any better than that
I'm really honestly it's been a pleasure
and an honor working with this group
it's it's I've seen some folks with
helmets extraordinary I don't I don't
know why how it articulate what and
metric what an epic collision and story
this is going to be I think the thing to
do right now is to bring the rest of the
cast tell them yeah let's do it
ladies gentlemen please welcome to stage
Holly Hunter
the sinister Jesse Eisenberg
then it's turkey super citizen look
anybody got a blazer off that people
out of one suit and into another back on
our stage
Oh
wonderful
when it all out
all right oh thank you sack so the first
one is for people here who are not DC
experts
not everybody has read every DC book
three people in the back never slept how
canonical is this conflict how rooted in
canon is the Batman V Superman conflict
or is it something that was created for
this film because personally I never
heard of it till now
well hey I mean listen you know the if
you want to talk about the story itself
or about the sort of particulars of this
movie about something that we it's
definitely based on just ideas that we
had you know in a room talking about
like what would be cool to see now the
idea that man find Superman is not is
not a it to be it's a thing that happens
all time common sense um but you know
for me it was just like there's a bunch
of images and this fellow I'll talk
about my sort of glove of a particular
comic book which is that you know the
Dark Knight Returns which is you know a
comic book that I love in a handy I I
definitely owe my a lot in the movie as
a way of staying to Frank Miller like
your genius and I think that book is
genius but the story itself is not that
story the story itself is a story that
we came up with just um you know on our
own Chris Terrio who is the amazing
writer of the the screenplay um you know
as a genius he worked with Ben on
article an amazing job and that movie is
great and you know he and he you know
he's you know you and I just you know we
just talked about like like how do you
make this make sense like what is the
lie of Batman fighting two men and
there's a lotta we have a lot of great
we add up stuff in Mansfield they've
actually allowed us to create a conflict
that really makes sense for
but this movies about and also sarlat
you toward what could be bigger
conflicts with maybe more more other
superheroes home who knows I mean I know
I mean I do know but I really know Eric
comic tease yeah thank you work through
that with me guys
this is also the person we're seeing
Batman and Superman together anything
scream you've seen in the books before
obviously many times and it's also first
time we both have peple of Gotham and
metropolis together so again how do you
merge those universes what rules did you
follow and what goals did you break yeah
well I mean I think the rule with the
big role that we broke is we put Gotham
and metropolis right next to each other
I don't know if it appeared that way
ever maybe somewhere probably it's been
you know if you dig deep enough you can
find a justification for just about
everything but it makes sense to us and
work for our story that they were a kind
of sister cities you know across the big
bay and so you had kind of like Oakland
in San Francisco kind of a lot yeah I'm
from San Francisco San Francisco would
win I think okay metropolis we look
people know this world and they think
they know this world intimately but
there have been so many iterations and
so many reboots obviously in the DC
Universe
I want to talk a little bit about the
panel here because this is a pretty
iconic group of characters that people
know that have been played before we
could just go down the line and talk a
little bit about what create a challenge
that presents when you're playing a
character that's been laying before
multiple times meant multiple actors
what do you get what do you stay true to
from the Canon and what do you invent
and was that challenging for you that
ever going to just find a new way to the
character was simple I don't know should
we start would like to start
well Michael Caine was pretty amazing so
I had big shoes to sitting but some he's
a little different
Alfred so I think there are surprises in
store but I carried along myself on the
explosions around me and on the world
around me I followed the boss and tried
to make him happy and trying to make him
safe and trying to make you grow up a
little well for me with Wonder Woman I
feel like I have been given such a huge
opportunity to show this strong
beautiful side of women finally and
Wonder Woman has all the strength of a
superhero but at the same time at the
same time she's very sophisticated
loving and has a lot of emotional
intelligence so for me I feel very very
privileged to be the one who's going to
bring her back to mine and I just can't
wait to celebrate I was gonna say the
thing about the strong independent woman
but she took know my character has been
in obviously other movies you know
there's always kind of like I can't be
element to the character but
probably in terms of your question I
think there's probably a real kind of
emotional roundedness to this version of
it and I treated that to that writer for
stereo was just such a phenomenal writer
and gives every character in this movies
like real emotional core even though the
situations are so - yes yeah also at the
most luxurious locks of any Luthor have
a really very this creep I've never been
to comic-con I just realized you guys
are awesome I'm gonna enter like um Lois
Lane I wanted to be Lois Lane since I
was five years old so there we go and I
watched it was Superman - on repeat over
and over and over
um but when that when the opportunity
arose of course I was nervous I wanted
to you know make you guys all happy with
Lois but at the same time I was just
willing and open to sort of bring a very
modern take on her and and then just
sort of embrace again this really strong
woman and then it's this wonderful thing
that women have where we had this
emotional intelligence and and the
vulnerability along with strength that I
thought was really a beautiful disaster
for me well obviously especially just
really did such a fantastic job I
reserved it was that dangerous video and
we near that so I left that to its own
and then just with Zack on Man of Steel
built the character as much as I could
drawing from the Canon and when I just
try to follow that state rate the
character that we we ran away the amount
of steel I think if I if I thought too
hard about the actors who played this
part before I couldn't take the job I
mean Tim Burton Val Kilmer George
Clooney
the great Christian Bale and I talked to
Zach about I was like are you sure you
know and he said I have this vision I
have this idea for the guy and you're
perfect for it that's what do you mean
he's me to get there and there's a row
he's older he's like a Burnout
but in truth - thank you thanks mom yeah
the truth was that he took me through
the process of creating his character
that I quite almost didn't see and at
the end of it I was like even sort of
astonished - look at him go that's
exactly what you ditched me and I wasn't
even sure I was I was doing it I had
this really weird experience where
before we started the movie I was
getting my kid a Halloween costume and
my son is really in Nevada and why is
Lee and he he went to a store a costume
store Los Angeles
it was pretty empty and I was in the
aisle and I had his voice and I turn
around its it's Christian Bale was the
sweetest guy and there he and I are
standing in the Batman comics and I said
look man you know you're the best like
what do you think you got any tips to
make sure you do that soon
yeah with a zipper on it oh did you
actually I think every we put a zipper
on this you're soon retroactive really
this time Deb is not you don't think of
these things
how's it gonna be fine how long is he
gonna be a like 50 now is that all I can
let me just say I'm just saying holly
has an original part in the film I'm in
such a giant anomalies forever we were
ready to script I was like okay we need
to find my feet we need to write a part
for Holly 100 places really I don't care
what the f it is but it turned off it's
in a super important part so that's a
very specific question right which part
of the title V Superman can I help
very good you know you've heard this a
million times since we started
developing this film again for driving
times after who would win a fight
between Batman and Superman now I'm not
gonna ask that question today it's gonna
combine a whole movie about
because central to this conflict is an
amor you know an immortal man you know
God as you articulated in a film versus
the human being which begs a lot of
other questions about kind of you know I
was embracing on the humanity and what
that means
however this Batman seems to be mecha
Batman he's a little bit effective thing
I think the thing to look at in the we
call it the next day whatever but it
really in truth it's not it's a stealth
preservation the concept about to you
know if anything away but it's not
really enhancing his strength more than
protecting him buying him time if you
will from everything you know it's it's
right you have to say anyway
clearly in the movie you do a lot of
philosophical issue who's in the film
and what I was wondering is if any of
what you won't do maybe perhaps change
the way that you look at month now you
just stated orrible through the entire
question
whoever has come tough me to say that I
play it going so I'm gonna step away I
think there are some really interesting
does that Chris put together some really
interesting ideas of you know metropolis
being a big successful city in Gotham
City being a place where a lot more
downtrodden people live and there's a
fairy they take across people who work
and the travelers take from Gotham City
and the whole idea of you know wealth
and power and power and genders feeder
and there were a lot of really ideas
that were a little bit too smart for me
to understand but that the movie was
trafficking in and I made it feel real
to me and smart and so I was even more
proud to be part of it this is from
someone who make a movie that I had to I
had to go to Wikipedia every five
minutes to understand hard metal but
sure yeah Superman versus Batman okay
this guy's tattoos yeah he's got tattoos
on the scabs how do I know that I've
seen it before but when you guys were
filming the movie and what point in time
did you say oh my god we're coming up
with something great awesome we're gonna
blow all of your guys's minds away
without spoilers but if you do or spy
please thank you while shooting the
movie
I feel like yes I mean feel like the
truth is I mean when you're shooting a
movie there are moments when you shoot
the movie then feel like wow this is
cool I mean just for instance when but
actually when we were doing we get a
little photo shoot um you know while
everyone's getting their talking
together
and it's like Wonder Woman and Superman
Batman all sort of standing there in the
pictures thanking you and oh my lord
that's crazy okay
but I think that you know for me it
actually happens long before that you
know when we're just kind of figuring
out what we're gonna do and I'm drawing
and we're just kind of good ideas of you
know different kind of images that we're
gonna create and I just normally this is
gonna sound weird but I'm by myself when
that's happening um and I don't do
anything weird sure but it is there is
that moment like when you do like if you
do a doodle and you're like oh my lord I
know that that's I want to see that I
want to I want to
let's wear the cameras we need to get
where's everybody come on let's go shoot
business so I think that that's really
for me the moment I don't know like for
these guys that they had different
experiences of course they probably live
it
goodbye at I'm also I'm still me I've
seen the costume a thousand times you
know it's it's like a love scene you
know there was everyone talks about all
but you know a love scene isn't sexy and
I don't know either the movie I've only
witnessed it that would be weird
anyway say the actors are always like
you know it's like this is done so I
don't know if they have that same
feeling when they're in their superhero
costume I had a feeling we're you know I
first almost said Christian Bale was
also buying his son the suit he doesn't
just hang out
but for me you know like you look at the
cast you look at the script and that's
so much of what's there and I always
thought you can only tweak a certain
amount past that because you can almost
kind of made the movie and I remember a
day about two weeks in it where I read
the sea and I thought about how to play
that came in and watched it I thought
okay yeah we should probably like shoot
it this way or that way and Zach set the
shot up so that it was one shot put it
on a crane and it came around and it
covered everybody's dialogue and it kind
of encompassed the scope what I do have
to say I'm coming never to that that's
so good
sorry it says people are under 18 but
anyway that's I remember thinking that
we were in good hands we just Holly that
20 or something at your beautiful mouth
having us we just shoot the last night
in Toronto but we had to come down
because we had a committee report in the
hall age because you guys run this
okay for you this is DC Comics ship
right here it's all about cannon it's
all about big fake little the source
material do you guys know who you are
and you know what you want you're going
to freakin get it with this show okay
and all this you know good versus evil
shit's kind of played out right now it's
fine for bad versus evil right it's time
for a movie about bad guys and who's got
the best bad guys out there
DC Comics best villains ever now I'm not
trying to start knowing you know East
Coast West code feud with Marvel Comics
now but hey someone's gotta say the
truth alright now I got a little a
little footage I want to show you guys
we've been working really hard
unfortunately a lot of people of iPhones
have been running around grabbing it so
it's a little something I found on the
internet that I'd like to show you so
let's go ahead and spin it do you guys
want to meet the cast alright let me get
around here presenting katana character
bahara
Slipknot out of Beach
enchantress card uh LaVon
Diablo Jimenez
Philip Braque on the wall a budget
that boomerang Jack horn a turtle red
flag Joe Gipp man watch out for this
next one Amanda Waller Viola Davis see
Harley Quinn Margot Robbie and the man
who cannot miss Will Smith's Deadshot
all right that's kind of it thanks for
having us guys we got to go back to work
want to say something hey listen but at
suicide squad we've been in Toronto this
group right here we were banging out
something that is absolutely fantastic
and and stunning and this guy right here
David Hare is the absolute truth is
making South Europe but of love deep
there will see your neck Suicide Squad
you